marie france bazzo bazzo on n'a jamais
autant parlé de cannabis cette semaine
il ça ne fait que commencer ça ne fait
que commencer on a pour pour un an
c'est cette semaine sur toutes les
antennes le sujet de débat numéro un au
canada
la légalisation du cannabis at elle
changé nos rapports avec les drogues
enrichir l'état au détriment des
contribuables qui devront eux payer le
prix des abus au niveau des soins de
santé au travail ou sur la route
bon c'est une des promesses les plus
revendiquer de justin trudeau il avait
parlé de ça abondamment qui en période
électorale
mais justement qu'est l'urgence quel
événement qu'elle est si d'un ont-ils
poussé à agir si vite probablement la
seule raison qu'on voit en fait à vue de
nez c'est probablement juste une manière
de pavie sont sony gouez passeport pour
le paradis des licornes dans l'univers
de justin trudeau d'affirmer la
coolitude du canada la légalisation de
la marijuana pourrait devenir avec les
années une poule aux oeufs d'or
un peu comme l'a été l'alcool pour le
gouvernement les recettes fiscales de la
vente de cannabis en 2018 devrait varier
de 418 à 618 millions de dollars en
fonction d'un prix de la marijuana qui
serait autour de 9 dollars le gramme
60% des revenus reviendrait aux
provinces alors que le reste 40%
tomberait dans les coffres du
gouvernement central jean denis
fréchette et le directeur parlementaire
du budget à ottawa
effectivement l'examen s'est pas
seulement il ne faut pas que tu as trop
ils ne peuvent pas trop écrit beaucoup
de pascal jean denis fréchette estime
que les gouvernements s'aventure en
terrain incertain et qu'ils auront peu
de marge de manoeuvre fiscale pour
appliquer une taxe raisonnable sans
pousser le prix de la drogue
significativement au dessus de celui du
marché noir
la sensibilité du prix les gens sont
très très sensible à la variation du
prix
d'un produit comme la mairie ouanna on a
des exemples ailleurs on notre modèle on
a démontré qu'on a pris un dollar de
plus pour le marché légal congrès tout
marché illégal des jaunes la
consommation bbc tadic ont passé 2 d'une
part de consommation 2 56% à 35 % du
marché
les gages parce que le marché légal
coûteux que ça alors le guen va vite
rivaux vitry est dit qu ils peuvent pas
jouer beaucoup sur ce marché de taille
aussi noté que le marché illégal
il est gage du billet ne sera pas plus
démantelés cet héros qu'il sera passée
dans lequel je marchais les gars quand à
la rippe thameur c'est pas quelque chose
qui va être facile pour le grade de
rentrer il de pénétrer ce marché de
façon légale parce que le marché illégal
sera toujours où henry pendant un
certain temps les suivants puis le
rapport du directeur parlementaire du
budget estime que le potentiel fiscal du
marché de la marijuana légal devrait
toutefois croître avec les années les
coûts de la production de l'industrie
légale devrait diminuer au fil des
années afin de générer encore plus
d'espèces fiscale pour les gouvernements
sans augmenter le prix de vente
une combinaison gagnante mais le projet
de loi prévoit que les provinces auront
le droit de décider comment la marijuana
sera distribué et vendu nous ici surtout
à quel prix douce n'apparaît donc faire
chavirer un modèle de commercialisation
et donc les revenus
s'il ya trop d'écart entre les provinces
donc il faut que l'âge soit à peu près
la même l'accès au cannabis soit peu
près la même que les points de
distribution soit similaire
et c'est serge brochu et directeur
scientifique de l'institut universitaire
sur les dépenses à l'université de
montréal premier ministre justin trudeau
nous mentionne que c'est pour mieux
contrôler et pour enlever les énormes
profits qu fait le marché criminel pour
mais si on veut éliminer ce profit au
niveau du marché criminel se soit pas du
jour au lendemain
vos premièrement essaie de garder une
partie du marché donc si les taux de thc
sont limités dont à 5% au niveau de la
vente légale elles vont essayer de se
spécialiser dans un niveau de th est un
peu plus élevé c'est
et les heures d'ouverture sont ne sont
pas compatibles avec les airs de
consommation ils vont se spécialiser
dans ce créneau
mais si on leur laisse pas suffisamment
d'espacé au niveau du marché illégal et
c'est souhaitable
ils vont essayer de rester sur le marché
donc de façon légale parce qu'ils
connaissent très bien les normes profits
qu'ils peuvent faire sur ce marché la
légalisation du cannabis à des fins
récréatives entraînera d'abord des
dépenses pour les gouvernements c'est ce
qu'affirme la présidente du groupe de
travail qui a dû se pencher sur le
dossier
mandaté par le gouvernement l'an dernier
pour faire une révision de toutes les
opinions au pays sur la question
à mi clown un ancien ministre libéral de
la santé de la justice affirmé en
entrevue à radio canada il faudra
financer des campagnes de prévention
importante pour former du personnel
aussi dans la foulée de la légalisation
l exemple d etat du colorado et du
washington qui ont dû absorber de telles
dépenses
dès le départ un reportage de radio
canada international